yes the uh regulator off gem has
announced that the new price cap for a
standard use average use of the dual
fuel bill will rise to 1971
pounds that's up uh just almost exactly
700 pounds from the current rate of uh
127 pounds so a major increase nudging
50 percent as many analysts had
predicted it reflects a huge increase in
wholesale gas prices that have driven up
the cost for suppliers over the last six
months have caused more than 25
suppliers of energy to go bust placing
pressure right across the board
stripping out the cheaper options the
switching options for customers to seek
cheaper bills and they are now looking
at from april the first the average uh
dual fuel bill will be capped at 1
971 pounds that is forecast to push at
least another 2 million households into
fuel stress or fuel poverty and it will
of course beg a response from the
government this is the kind of price
increase to a necessary utility that no
one can do without
that is going to affect not just the
poorest in society but median income
households
almost everyone is going to feel the
scale of this in their pockets worth
remembering that a year ago the price
cap was just over a thousand pounds so
it has very nearly doubled in the space
of
a year and if today's news wasn't enough
for people to uh try and digest the
forecast is in the six months time given
the ex the state of the gas market and
the expectation prices will remain high
it could be going up again too well
north of 2000 pounds so we will hear in
the next half hour or so the response
from the floor of the house of commons
from the chancellor of the exchequer
we've talked about we've had uh
briefings and suggestions of various
measures to uh take money off these
bills perhaps 200 pounds rebated to
every customer but given the stay scale
of this increase the price cap now just
shy of 2 000 pounds even a 200 pound
rebate is going to leave
every household at least certainly 22
million households who are on standard
variable rates are still going to be
looking at a 500 pound increase of 50
pounds a month
getting on for 50 pounds a month anyway
increasing their fuel bills and with
interest rates due to go up later today
inflation as it stands north of 5 and
tax rises coming in april uh there will
be a great deal of attention on what the
chancellor announces he's going to do
about this cost of living squeeze in
about half an hour